this looks crazy it does it looks like
this looks like something you would have
3d printed whoo-hoo what is a spicy
roasted fish crackers
it smells like a bait and tackle shop
spicier than I thought how do I get I
like it I don't taste the fish at all
actually
does it mean you know what fish tastes
like oh I do smack fish on things and
going yes sure balls they are not afraid
to use balls chicky balls do chickens
have balls
it says balls actually all it says is
balls there's I got ball of dirt cheese
I think cheese are they chicken it's
exactly what I thought it would taste I
mean that guy's balls
I mean thoroughness it looks like a net
made of seaweed this is like a real
savory flavor tastes almost like olives
and pickles not like pickles or like
olives like olive oil tastes like
seaweed crackers it smells like play-doh
it does smell like play-doh
what does it taste like play-doh and I
know that cuz I used to eat later
everyone did your own special pass it
was also a route yeah you guys does not
have potatoes oh man I'm lying about a
taste of my mouth sorry on fire this is
delicious it's delicious how many
calories are missing what does this
taste like it tastes like cereal ninety
five and ninety five dollars in point
nine ounces oh I don't even think you
can eat a whole bag is anyone here in
fact cazuca chips also the same as crack
cocaine indestructible is that weird
that's like a secret cuca Goom which is
a fresh daily snacks how great for a
petrified styrofoam breakup a gift
cardboard smells like paint it taste
like styrofoam with an aftertaste of
this which is exactly what I want my
styrofoam to taste like you could
probably build a building with this
every single one of these things has
been harder than I thought I am
concerned we just ate stucco why would
you eat this why did you eat - I don't
know I'm I'm concerned we just ate stuck
up